[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et on accueille aujourd'hui
notre invité Xavier yakovelli bonjour
vous êtes sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine
membre du groupe RDPI au Sénat c'est à
dire le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle dont vous êtes le
vice-président bonjour bonjour et nous
parlerons de cette première semaine
d'examen à l'Assemblée nationale de la
réforme des retraites un débat très
agitées et qui tournent au ralenti
parallèlement la mobilisation contre la
réforme se poursuit et les syndicats
veulent durcir le mouvement à partir du
7 mars et dans ce contexte la droite
sénatoriale propose une loi pour limiter
le droit de grève dans les transports au
début et à la fin des vacances scolaires
et puis on parlera de la guerre en
Ukraine le Sénat voté mardi à une forte
majorité une proposition de résolution
qui demande que la France renforce
l'armement de l'armée ukrainienne dans
cette guerre alors que le président
ukrainien veut le dire Zelinski est venu
cette semaine rencontrer ses alliés
européens et notamment Emmanuel Macron
les députés continuent donc de débattre
de la réforme des retraites la
discussion avant lentement dans la
douleur prise dans le tunnel des plus de
20 000 amendements déposés à l'ouverture
des débats majorité et opposition des
fonds
[Applaudissements]
sa voix couverte par une bronca venue
des bancs de la gauche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis dans une manif on est dans les
piscines de l'Assemblée nationale
dès le départ le débat sur les retraites
a tourné à l'affrontement anthroposition
et gouvernement quelle lumière
allumez-vous pour les Français rien
juste cette petite chose banale mesquine
etriquée une réforme des retraites vous
faites pitié oui à la diminution du
temps de travail oui endroit là paresse
oui on doit la retraite à 60 ans votre
projet ça sera l'effondrement du système
de retraite qui souffrirait de la baisse
des pensions les retraités modestes pas
les milliardaires un débat loin d'être
en sourdine mais proche du dialogue de
sourd d'un côté une gauche décidait à
faire entendre la colère sociale dans
l'hémicycle la tempête sociale qui se
prépare va balayer collègues de l'autre
un gouvernement une majorité qui
justifie la réforme
c'est toutes c'est pas tous pour des
intérêts particuliers dès l'article
premier la suppression des régimes
spéciaux les députés de la nuque
monopolisent la parole est contrôlent le
temps des débats qui s'enlise dans une
multitude d'amendements souvent
similaire quand on dépose un amendement
pour chacune des années entre 2028 et
2050 c'est bien pour moi de
l'obstruction une stratégie dénoncée à
l'autre bord de l'échiquier par le
rassemblement national vous êtes les IDI
sa vie a couru des débats avancent très
lentement à l'Assemblée entre les
rappels aux règlements les suspensions
de séance on a quand même l'impression
au vu de ce qui se passe notamment sur
cet article 1 sur lequel les députés
sont toujours que c'est plutôt la gauche
qui mène le débat c'est surtout la
gauche et la
nupsi qui font de l'obstruction parce
que les débats on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui que les débats avancent et
que le texte peut être amélioré je pense
que c'est ça quand on est député quand
on est parlementaire notre rôle c'est de
faire avancer les débats de faire en
sorte que les textes qui nous
conviennent ou pas puissent être
améliorés par le débat parlementaire par
le travail parlementaire et on voit bien
que la volonté sur les 20 000
amendements déposés à l'Assemblée
nationale 18 viennent des rangs de la
nuque on voit bien qu'il y a une
obstruction organisée de leur part pour
ralentir et pour pour infiner ne pas
voter ce texte certes mais on a
l'impression quand même que le
gouvernement elle a rapporté n'est pas
très ne sont pas très ouverts à aux
propositions venues de l'opposition non
je suis pas d'accord avec vous
on a vu il y a déjà eu une évolution
pendant ces débats malgré tout malgré
l'obstruction il y a eu quand même une
évolution sur la prise en compte par
exemple des carrières à longues à partir
de 20 ans et donc ça c'est une évolution
annoncée par la première ministre sur la
question de avant parce qu'il y a eu des
débats en commission le débat
parlementaire ne se fait pas seulement
dans les métiers qui se fait aussi en
commission et donc entre la Commission
et l'hémicycle effectivement il y a eu
des avancées de la part du gouvernement
suite aux discussions en commission il y
a aussi un durcissement sur la question
de l'index seniors sur limiter les
licenciements qui qui sont un effet de
même parfois pour se débarrasser des
seigneurs et donc tout ça ce sont des
évolutions qui sont apportées par le
débattement a toujours dit qu'on était
ouvert aux propositions pour améliorer
le texte la seule ligne rouge que nous
avons c'est l'équilibre budgétaire de
notre système de retraite par
répartition et surtout de ne pas
organiser le démantèlement de notre
système par répartition parce que moi
j'entends les propositions de la LFI qui
veulent faire des ça c'est le plus de
taxes ça on entend bien mais le plus la
pluie de taxes ça sera pour compenser un
système structurellement déficitaire et
donc on sort du système par répartition
c'est à dire les actifs qui financent
les retraites alors Xavier c'est
évolutions que vous avez cité elles sont
notamment faites en direction des
républicains qui sur le papier était
plutôt favorable à cette réforme des
retraites mais il y a actuellement des
divisions chez LLR et notamment Aurélien
Pradier et plusieurs députés les
républicains qui le disent ils ne
voteront pas cette réforme de retraite
en l'état est-ce que ça vous inquiète
cette division chez les LR pour au final
obtenir une majorité sur cette réforme
des retraites les avancées elles sont
pas faites aux alentours enfin pour les
républicains elles sont faites surtout
pour les Français je reprends l'exemple
quand on durcit la question des
licenciements sur les seniors quand on
permet de une amélioration des carrières
longues à partir de 20 ans on voit bien
que ce n'est pour les Français c'est pas
pour les LR c'est pas pour la nul c'est
pas pour les filles
mais c'est demander par Aurélien Pradier
peut-être mais c'est aussi demandé par
les Français et c'est normal et donc
c'est et c'était d'ailleurs demandé par
un certain nombre de députés de de la
majorité également donc nous avons
besoin effectivement de faire avancer ce
texte moi je crois à la responsabilité
aujourd'hui des parties de gouvernement
de ceux qui se revendiquent encore comme
des parties de gouvernement les
républicains en font partie ça fait des
années qui le revendiquent la retraite à
65 ans au Sénat c'était même 64 ans on a
un amendement dans chaque PLFSS sur
l'allongement à 64 ans donc je pense que
les républicains infinés seront
cohérents avec ce qu'ils défendent
depuis des années c'est normal que le
débat est mieux c'est normal qu'il
puisse aussi avancer un certain nombre
de propositions et qui puisse débattre
avec avec le gouvernement sur leurs
attentes mais une fine et je moi je
crois à la responsabilité des députés de
la majorité présidentielle et des
républicains et de tous ceux qui qui
aspirent à avoir pérennisé notre système
de retraite alors les députés discutent
ardemment de la suppression de certains
régimes spéciaux de retraite certains
seulement mais pas tous la France compte
une multitude de régimes spéciaux des
casses autonomes c'est d'ailleurs assez
complexe comme système est-ce que vous
comprenez qu'on ait décidé de supprimer
certains j'ai spéciaux celui de la RATP
de la Banque de France et d'en conserver
d'autres quelle est la justification au
fond Armand à titre personnel je suis
pour la suppression de tous les régimes
spéciaux je crois pas des caisses
autonomes c'est différent et les régimes
spéciaux effectivement moi je pense que
il faut qu'aujourd'hui que nous ayons le
même système pour pour tout le monde
quand on est conducteur de bus à
Beauvais et bah effectivement on doit
avoir les mêmes droits à la retraite
qu'un conducteur de bus à Paris ça me
paraît logique c'est le même métier et
donc à même métier même même droit et
même devoir et donc moi je suis
favorable à ça après il y a un certain
nombre de régimes dont vous avez parlé
qui sont plutôt des régimes autonomes
des caisses autonomes et là dans ces cas
là ça s'autofinance en tout cas ce n'est
pas forcément toujours compensé par du
régime des sénateurs un régime autonome
que certains députés proposent de
supprimer c'est le régime de retraite
autonome du Sénat alors pour bien
l'expliquer c'est un régime qui
fonctionne avec
il cette réflexion c'est normal qu'elle
soit posée moi j'ai pas j'ai rien contre
l'évolution de notre système de retraite
il doit évoluer et d'ailleurs le
président l'archet l'a toujours dit que
on alignerait le l'âge de la retraite au
même titre que le régime général et donc
on voyait qu'il y a toujours eu des
évolutions de la Caisse autonome de
retraite alors on va clore cette
séquence de l'examen du texte à
l'Assemblée avec une petite image très
remarquée à l'Assemblée nationale mardi
vers 22h30 Adrien catenen ça demandait à
prendre la parole pour défendre un
amendement suscitant la bronca dans les
rangs de la majorité Xavier yakovelli
alors rappelons qu'il a été condamné
Adrien katnas pour violence conjugale
mais sans écoper d'une peine
éligibilité pardon qu'est-ce qui empêche
Adrien katnas de siéger et de prendre
part au débat
écoutez moi je n'ai pas pour habitude de
commenter les décisions de justice il a
été condamné pour violence conjugales
moi je pense avant tout à toutes les
victimes de violences conjugales qu'il
ait pris la parole lorsque de se débat
sur la retraite ou pas je veux pas je
veux pas rentrer dans ce système si ça
me choque ou pas il est il a été c'est
un représentant du peuple il a été élu
par le peuple c'est le peuple qui peut
lui reprendre son mandat et personne
d'autre en l'occurrence les juges qui
auraient pu effectivement le prononcer
une peine d'éligibilité ce n'est pas le
cas je pense qu'il faut retrouver un peu
de sérénité quelques dans tous les bancs
de l'Assemblée nationale quelle que soit
l'étiquette politique je pense que on a
besoin d'avancer sur ce sur cette
réforme des retraites on a besoin
d'avoir des débats sereins je pense que
c'est pas à l'image aujourd'hui de de ce
que les Français attendent des
représentants de du peuple et donc voilà
après il a pris la décision de ne pas se
mettre en retrait de l'Assemblée
nationale de ne pas démissionner de son
poste il en a le droit moi à titre
personnel je pense qu'effectivement
ces actes sont condamnables et ils ont
été condamnés maintenant je pense qu'on
peut passer à autre chose et continuer à
travailler sur la réforme des retraites
ce qu'attendent des Français vous avez
ecovelli on travaille au Sénat sur la
réforme des retraites et on se projette
déjà sur le débat qui aura lieu à la
Haute Assemblée ce sera du 2 au 12 mars
comment vous envisagez ce débat au
groupe RDP de la majorité présidentielle
est-ce que vous allez porter des
améliorations et puis est-ce que vous
craignez une autre obstruction de la
gauche sénatoriale qui dit qu'elle va
utiliser toutes les procédures pour
s'opposer au texte alors bien sûr nous
au sein du groupe la majorité
présidentielle on travaille sur sur ce
texte on a commencé les auditions dans
le cadre de la commission des affaires
sociales donc moi je suis chef de fil
avec Martin lévrier pour le groupe
majorité présidentielle donc on commence
les auditions ça passera en commission
le le premier le premier mars et puis on
va voir aussi l'évolution du texte au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale parce que
ça va dépendre aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas porter un certain nombre
d'amendements qui pourraient être déjà
pas repris à l'Assemblée nationale donc
on va voir l'évolution du texte et suite
au texte qui sortira d'assemblée
nationale nous porterons effectivement
un certain nombre de propositions
d'améliorations du texte ou de
suppression de de
d'éléments qui pourraient aller à
l'encontre de l'équilibre que nous
recherchons pour pérenniser notre
système de retraite totalement aligné
sur le gouvernement mais vous savez moi
je crois à l'initiative parlementaire
nous sommes solidaires du gouvernement
nous sommes dans cette majorité
présidentielle après nous avons aussi
des propositions des choses à dire au
sein du groupe de la majorité
présidentielle comme les députés de la
majorité présidentielle ont aussi leur
mot à dire sur sur ce texte et c'est
normal des amendements ont été déposés
aujourd'hui par la majorité
présidentielle et l'Assemblée nationale
donc il est normal que les groupes qui
composent la majorité présidentielle au
Sénat puissent en faire de même une
question sur la mobilisation est sur les
grèves les syndicats ont indiqué qu'ils
souhaitaient durcir le mouvement à
partir du 7 mars avec des grèves
reconductibles et d'ailleurs ce jeudi
Emmanuel Macron leur a demandé
je cite responsable et de ne pas bloquer
la vie du reste du pays en quoi ce
serait irresponsable de faire des grèves
recondues déjà je voulais saluer leur
décision qui a été de ne pas bloquer le
pays pendant les périodes de vacances et
notamment ce samedi pour les départs en
vacances d'un certain nombre de zones
après que les syndicats organisent des
manifestations de contestation c'est
légitime et on ne remet pas ça en cause
le fait de bloquer le pays bloqué à la
fois l'économie bloquée ceux qui
souhaitent aller travailler ceux qui
souhaitent aussi avoir des loisirs je
pense que là c'est effectivement
irresponsable on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
bloquer un pays pour contester le droit
de grève
le gouvernement restera inflexible ou
alors peut bouger mais vraiment le
blocage de certains secteur stratégique
est organisé je pense qu'il faut sortir
de cette idée que ce n'est pas la rue
qui fait la loi et qui fait la loi dans
le bon sens du terme dans le sens où la
loi est faite par les parlementaires et
donc aujourd'hui le débat a eu lieu a
lieu actuellement à l'Assemblée
nationale il aura lieu au Sénat c'est au
parlementaire aux représentant du peuple
décrire la loi de voter la loi et ça ne
peut pas se faire avec la pression de la
rue que des manifestations ait lieu
qu'une contestation qui est légitime
puisse s'exprimer c'est tout à fait
normal mais ce n'est pas encore une fois
les syndicats qui écrivent la loi alors
pour faire face aux perturbations
engendrées par les grèves dans les
transports et bien le sénateur les
républicain Stéphane Le régulier a
déposé une proposition de loi pour
interdire à la grève dans les transports
au début et à la fin des vacances
scolaires on va l'écouter
cette proposition est née d'un constat
nous sommes en
décembre 2022
il y a 200000 français qui ont été
privés du rassemblement familial j'ai
été assez surpris que une minorité
d'individus puisqu'il s'agissait cela en
dehors de tout contexte d'organisation
syndicale puisse prendre en
otage 200 000 Français le droit de grève
doit être encadré par le législateur
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire un
blogement de poser des moments des
périodes cruciales pour les familles
pour qu'elles puissent être assurée de
circuler librement sur l'ensemble du
territoire français Xavier aquare est-ce
que vous pourriez voter cette
proposition de loi
je suis partagé moi j'attends de voir
effectivement le texte en détail mais je
pense que le droit de grève il est déjà
encadré il y a déjà un service minimum
normalement qui qui doit s'exercer après
c'est aussi la responsabilité des
syndicats c'est à dire que le droit de
grève il est constitutionnel et il faut
le défendre après ça ne peut pas non
plus être un droit de blocage et un
droit de pourrir la vie des Français et
donc effectivement le fait de bloquer
les transports au moment du départ en
vacances au moment d'un certain nombre
d'événements de regroupement familial je
pense notamment au fait de Noël comme on
a pu le vivre dernièrement ça ce n'est
pas normal ce n'est pas responsable donc
moi j'appelle plutôt à la responsabilité
des syndicats plutôt que d'organiser une
limitation du droit de grève qui est un
droit encore une fois constitutionnel et
que je défends pourtant on ne comprend
pas bien vous dites que le service
minimum existe une loi de 2007 qui a
instauré cette obligation service
minimum et dans les faits cette loi
n'est pas appliquée est-ce que c'est
normal pour vous et pourquoi non bah de
toute façon une loi qui n'est pas
appliquée ce n'est pas normal par
principe
donc peut-être renforcer le service
minimum faire en sorte effectivement que
cette loi soit effective dans les
transports en commun mais je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il faille interdire les droits de
grève pendant les périodes de vacances
scolaires ça ira à l'encontre du droit
de grève donc voilà je vous ai dit ce
que j'en pensais je pense qu'il faut ne
pas pourrir la vie des Français appelé à
la responsabilité des syndicats et en
plus moi je pense sincèrement que c'est
contre-productif pour les syndicats
aujourd'hui d'appeler à la grève les
jours de départ en vacances parce que ça
leur paie ils perdent le l'opinion
publique de qui pourrait les soutenir
sur ces mouvements donc je pense faisons
en sorte d'être responsable oui au droit
de grève non au blocage du pays allez on
va parler de la guerre en Ukraine
puisque mardi dernier le Sénat a voté à
une grande majorité une proposition de
résolution pour soutenir l'Ukraine dans
cette guerre et renforcer la livraison
d'armes à l'armée ukrainienne Fabien
Ricard
c'est un texte transpartisan tout signé
par 5 présidents de groupes politiques
et adopté mardi à une large majorité le
Sénat réaffirme le soutien de la France
à l'Ukraine et condamne la guerre
d'agression menée par Moscou la chambre
haute appelle notamment la France et ses
alliés a poursuivre les livraisons de
matériel militaires aux Ukrainiens si
l'Europe est une paix durable sur le
continent elle doit apprendre le langage
de la puissance le seul que les
dictateurs comprennent mieux vaut tard
que jamais c'est maintenant qu'il faut
livrer les chars les missiles les
défenses solaires et les avions si nous
voulons comme le Prométhée le président
de la République lors de ses vœux
accompagné l'Ukraine jusqu'à la victoire
finale une semaine après la venue du
président du parlement ukrainien au
Sénat la question des livraisons d'armes
fait consensus y compris chez une partie
de la gauche soit nous livrons à
l'Ukraine davantage d'armement de pointe
pour lui permettre de percer à nouveau
le front et d'avancer vers l'Est soit la
guerre va inévitablement s'enliser dans
un mercurier conflit de tranchées ou
périront tant de soldats que la Russie a
en nombre supérieur la résolution
dénonce également les attaques sur les
populations civiles par les forces
russes et soutient l'action de la Cour
pénale internationale pour enquêter sur
des crimes de guerre dans un conflit où
l'un
des deux sont
civiles par cette résolution chère
collègues dénonçons une dérive inhumaine
le groupe communiste a voté contre la
résolution redoutant les conséquences
d'une escalade militaire en cas de
poursuite des livraisons d'armements
abandonner l'objectif de la paix au sol
profit de l'escalade militaire c'est
abdiquer devant la perspective d'une
guerre longue et durable toujours plus
destructrice une guerre aux limites
inconnue chaque jour plus proche d'un
basculement conséquent un calculable
alors qu'approche le premier
anniversaire de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
on estime à plus de 100 000 le nombre de
victimes civiles et militaires du côté
ukrainien Xavier on a entendu l'auteur
de cette proposition de résolution
Claude Malleray à dire il faut livrer
les avions de chasse maintenant alors
que ce jeudi Emmanuel Macron après avoir
rencontré volody mirzelinski il le dit
il n'exclut pas de livrer des avions de
chasse mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas
la priorité et ce qu'il faut attendre
avant de livrer ses avions ou est-ce
qu'il faut les livrer rapidement alors
il a pas dit que ça le président de la
République il a dit aussi que on ne peut
pas livrer aujourd'hui des avions à
l'Ukraine sans avoir la formation des
des pilotes Ukrainiens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de d'utiliser ce type d'avion
sans avoir un certain nombre de garantie
et on ne peut pas comme ça livrer des
avions donc aujourd'hui du matériel des
avions de fabrication soviétique
aujourd'hui sous quoi l'engagement du
président de la République et
l'engagement de quasiment l'ensemble des
pays européens et de l'Union européenne
c'est de livrer des chars de livrer des
batteries
anti-aériennes de permettre la défense
des positions ukrainiennes de
d'augmenter effectivement le soutien de
l'Union européenne à l'Ukraine pour pour
se défendre mais aujourd'hui on n'est
pas encore dans une position de pouvoir
donner des avions notamment parce que on
n'a pas la formation des des pilotes
donc il y a besoin personne n'a exclu le
fait de livrer des avions le Premier
ministre britannique l'a rappelé cette
semaine le président de la rappeler ce
jeudi également donc nous n'exclons pas
de livrer des avions mais pour l'instant
la priorité c'est l'échard les missiles
et les défenses anti-aériennes et tout
de même livrer massivement des armements
de quel type qui soit sans plan de paix
derrière est-ce que ce n'est pas un peu
alimenté l'escalade militaire voir
l'enlisement aujourd'hui on est surtout
à faire en sorte que l'Ukraine puisse
retrouver sa se trouve ça souveraineté
territoriale depuis se protéger sa
population et se défendre contre un
envahisseur notamment la Russie on en
est là aujourd'hui on est à protéger les
populations vous l'avez rappelé dans
votre portage c'est 100 000 victimes
depuis le début de la guerre depuis
presque un an c'est
l'invasion de la part de la Russie sur
un territoire souverain et donc c'est ça
aujourd'hui que l'Union européenne que
le monde occidental dénonce et
et alimente c'est à dire qu'on aide les
Ukrainiens à se protéger contre contre
un envahisseur c'est avant tout avant
tout ça donc c'est pas une escalade de
la violence c'est permettre à l'Ukraine
de retrouver sa souveraineté
territoriale mais envoyer des avions de
chasse est-ce que ce ne serait pas entré
dans une guerre aérienne et donc dans
une escalade face à une puissance dotée
quand même de l'arme nucléaire la Russie
c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est
normal que aujourd'hui il y a une
prudence de l'Union européenne une
prudence des pays européens il ne faut
pas avoir la main qui tremble comme le
comme a dit Charles Michel sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine sur la livraison massive
d'armes et de mesure de défense pour
l'Ukraine la question des avions viendra
peut-être dans un second temps et
notamment en termes de soutien aérien
pour les forces terrestres mais
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur des forces
terrestres et des forces de défense
alors voilà des meilleurs zinsky a fait
une tournée en Europe cette semaine
Londres Paris-Bruxelles
Ukraine et candidate à l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne est-ce qu'il faut
selon vous accélérer ou pas cet adhésion
oui moi je le souhaite je le souhaite
parce que aujourd'hui
les Ukrainiens sont tournés depuis
plusieurs années maintenant vers vers
l'Europe on voit que les populations
ukrainiennes le demandent l'attendent et
je pense que la situation aujourd'hui
cette guerre avec la Russie pousse
encore plus les Ukrainiens vers le roc
vers l'Occident et donc je pense qu'il
faut accélérer cette cette adhésion et
ça va dans le bon sens et en plus ça
serait cohérent avec tout ce que nous
faisons depuis un an au niveau européen
sur ce sujet un Hidalgo a estimé qu'il
ne fallait pas accueillir d'athlètes
russes pour les prochains jeux
olympiques à Paris en 2024 est-ce
qu'elle a raison
c'est toujours compliqué alors j'avais
envie de dire une fois n'est pas coutume
je vais être d'accord avec Anne Hidalgo
sur cette question là c'est vrai que
c'est toujours compliqué de se dire que
le sport rentre dans un dans des
éléments politiques et géopolitiques et
en même temps il y a un principe de
réalité ça a toujours été le cas les
compétitions internationales ont
toujours été le reflet parfois de
conflit en tout cas les conflits
internationaux ont toujours été dans le
sport donc moi je regrette effectivement
que que ça soit le cas mais aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas accepter que des
représentants d'un pays qui agresse un
autre pays de la communauté
internationale puisse participer à un
moment de de joie un moment de partage
que sont les Jeux Olympiques et donc ça
me paraît logique aujourd'hui cette
position et je la défendrai plus tôt
allez on va finir cette émission en
jetant un coup d'oeil à l'agenda de la
semaine prochaine au Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'Assemblée nationale ce sera la
deuxième semaine d'examen du projet de
loi qui réforme les retraites les
députés ont très exactement jusqu'au 17
février minuit pas une minute de plus
pour espérer finir d'examiner la réforme
également à l'agenda l'audition de Bruno
Le Maire sur le pacte de stabilité il
sera notamment question des réformes
structurelles promises par la France à
Bruxelles et au Sénat la commission
d'enquête sur la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments auditionnera toute une
série d'anciennes ministres du logement
et notamment Cécile Duflot et Emmanuel
wargon et mercredi les sénateurs se
prépareront à l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat ils auditionneront
les syndicats et le patronat c'est la
fin de cette émission merci beaucoup
Xavier d'avoir été notre invité cette
semaine et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
et à très bientôt sur la chaîne
parlementaires ciao ciao
[Musique]